[Music]
deserted shopping malls half empty
apartment complexes abandoned
construction sites these are all signs
of the crisis that has gripped China's
property market and also an illustration
of how dramatically The Fortunes of this
sector have changed in the last few
years
home buyers are afraid of not getting
the home that they paid for the problems
China have now a deep seated structure
ones I think the consensus is already
that for China the property sales may
not go back to yesterday China's
property Market is in a bunch of trouble
and because property is the single
biggest contributor to China's GDP when
the properties actor is in trouble the
rest of the economy is in trouble as
well
[Music]
to understand why the property crisis
has happened now you have to go back a
few years
in the early 2000s there was an enormous
construction boom here skyscrapers
apartment complexes that were going up
everywhere there was this fundamental
belief that property prices could only
go up
that belief has been shaken tremendously
and when you speak to people now there's
a real worry that maybe what follows a
boom is Busters
[Music]
the privatization of property that began
in the 1990s created one of the largest
explosions of wealth in the country's
history
China's housing stock was dilapidated
and low quality many people living in
worn out dormitories or housing provided
by their state-owned Enterprise or
government Ministry
[Music]
China was urbanizing with tens of
millions moving from the countryside to
the city and China was getting richer
all of these things together would
already have driven an enormous boom in
China's real estate the trouble was
other factors also contributed
domestically the stock market has been
tumultuous there have been people who
have made a lot of money in the stock
market and also a lot of people who have
lost a lot of money at the same time
property was steady it just continued
going up up and up and so people began
buying homes not to live in them but as
a way to invest their money
for years there have been warnings about
the boring bench and the building bench
in China's property sector Chinese
developers would launch a project for
pre-sales get the money from the home
buyers and immediately invest a sum of
money into new land Parcels to keep
expanding and all work fine until cells
suddenly tumbled new cash stop coming in
and developers find they don't have
enough cash to finish the construction
of homes previously pre-sold
the build top of the bubbles went on
unchecked but as long as people kept
buying and there's a lot of investment
demands snapping up the oversupply of
housing investors and developers felt
great
that's until the party stops
[Applause]
income Xi Jinping from the beginning of
his second term as China's leader in
2017 he really starts putting his
shoulder into this Mantra that homes are
for living in not for speculating on
China's efforts to tighten regulation
over its developers culminated in the
unveiling of what's become known as the
three red lines policy in 2020 it
greatly limited the ability of those
firms to get financing a lot of smaller
companies ran into trouble almost
immediately then ever granted once the
country's biggest developer warned of a
potential cash crunch a year later it
was in default sending shock waves
through Global markets the day has
finally come Sherry we've been circling
around this what has very recently felt
like a complete inevitability right but
Evergreen now declaring officially in
default of problems at evergrand were
well recognized hedge funds have been
shorting the stock for years the
surprise though was the shift in
government policy from standing behind
the debts of big property developers to
allowing them to go under
dozens of private developers have since
collapsed raising not only questions
about the future of the property Market
in China but about the health of the
entire economy the latest struggle
Country Garden was once the country's
largest developer by sales and
accompanied many Saw as too big to film
Country Garden obviously the latest
poster child of the property sector was
the Fallen fortunes of country guard you
can basically see in a 10-year chart
the two that crisis is very different
country garden has over 3 000 projects
across China and that's four times
African for every Grand when it went but
in 2021 the government can still call in
an isolated event and it's due to the
company's own management and redness
expansion for developer of Country
Garden status to Stoneboro it's more
detrimental to sentiment because it's
telling you that some things
fundamentally wrong with China's housing
market that's pushing even formally
healthy developers to the brink of
collapse
as the developers suffered construction
stopped home buyers realized the
properties they had already paid for had
taken out a mortgage to buy were not
being built anger and protest grew
[Applause]
this is really the big concern
throughout all of the kind of Crackdown
is whether or not we're going to see
social unrest and financial instability
the government has stepped in to push
Banks to continue lending to developers
so that they have the money to finish
the homes that they've already sold and
make sure that those homes are delivered
to the buyers the government has also
stepped in to ask the banks to lower the
interest rates they charge on mortgages
foreign
of the wealth of the average Chinese
household is tied up in their homes when
that home price goes down they feel poor
they spend less and that has been a real
drag on the economy this year
the risks of the financial system we've
already started to see a big Trust
Company here in China a trillion U.N
under management has not been able to
pay some of its products when it comes
due because they lent a lot of money to
developers and they themselves have not
been paid if we start seeing problems in
China's Banks if there are concerns
about a Lehman movement for China what
we could see is a global risk off moment
for financial markets it wouldn't just
be Australia and Chile and the other
commodity producers that will be
suffering it will be the big Financial
Centers here in the United States in
London and elsewhere
when Lehman Brothers collapsed in 2008
it marked the beginning of a global
financial crisis we've had a historic
day on Wall Street Lehman Brothers the
158 year old firm filed for chapter 11
protected in U.S bankruptcy court today
but there are some key differences
between what happened then and what's
happening in China today
banks in China are much more
straightforward in their operations than
the Wall Street whiz kids that
contributed to the global financial
crisis China's banking system has very
ample sources of funding and has the
government standing squarely behind it
does that guarantee that China will
escape a financial crisis as the real
estate sector collapses
no but it gives them a Fighting Chance
if China's economy stumbles the global
implications will be far-reaching
touching anyone who's benefited from
having the country as a supplier or as
an end consumer geopolitically a
weakened Chinese economy could force
Beijing to reconsider how it pursues its
rivalry with Washington
and if other nations begin wondering
whether China is a superpower
approaching its peak the way the world
deals with Beijing may be in for a lot
of rethinking
[Music]